well with the coveted vaccine reaching
more arms across nevadans testing for
the virus may not be as popular as it
was months ago however victoria saha
joins us live with a closer look at why
hi victoria
we're seeing a slight increase in test
positivity rate for the state this week
that's the percentage of tests that come
up positive
the testing trend seems to be
inconsistent but vaccine allocation
has been increasing take a look last
month this time more than 7 thousand
tests were administered
yesterday's numbers neared only 4 600
tests
and today we are learning that there was
another jump with more than 8
000 tests administered over the past day
we've been talking about our test
positivity rate coming up
even though it's climbing you can see
it's still way below
than what it's been in the past they use
this number to figure out if there's
been an undiagnosed case
in the community the lower the better
however despite fluctuations state
health officials say
testing is still key to help stop the
spread of the virus
despite vaccinations being available
testing is still important
we still are confident in the number of
tests that are being turned in
are being reported and resulted into our
system that we are
tracking the appropriate trends
of the virus health officials say even
if you are fully vaccinated and think
you might have been exposed to the virus
it's best to get
tested as for vaccines more than 1.3
million doses have been administered in
nevada
reporting live from the newsroom
victoria saha 8 news now